It's great to welcome today John Thai to the
program, a former NSA whistleblower and a
lawyer who back in 2017 founded Whistleblower
Aid, which has provided support to the anonymous
Ukraine whistleblower, among many other things.
John, great to have you on today.
Thank you so much, David.
So let's start with your path.
Executive order.
Twelve, three, three, three.
What is it and how did that turn you into
a whistleblower?
Thanks.
I was at the State Department.
I worked in the Human Rights Bureau from 2011
to 2014 on Internet Freedom.
And in that role, I had a top secret clearance.
So I was reading intelligence from various
countries around the world.
And in June of 2013, the Snowden disclosures
became very public news.
And I was part of the diplomatic response
to those disclosures, both with Germany, Brazil,
other countries, the United Nations, the Human
Rights Council in Geneva.
And during that period and in the nine months
following that, I got a couple of briefings
from the NSA on the scope of U.S. signals
intelligence collection.
And what I learned was for that whole year
following the Snowden leaks, there hadn't
been a single story despite front page stories
almost every day, hadn't been a single story
on the main legal authority that the NSA is
using to collect American's data, which is,
as you said, executive order twelve, triple
three.
I was concerned about this.
I was interested.
I obviously care very deeply about human rights
and Americans privacy.
And so basically, this is a legal loophole
where the NSA is using an authority originally
intended to collect foreigners data to actually
sweep up most of what we do online, including
U.S. persons, American citizens.
This concerned me.
It wasn't being addressed in the in the policy
responses to the Snowden disclosures.
And during that period, I became a whistleblower.
I did not want to go to prison.
I did not want to leave the country.
And so I hired a couple of lawyers.
I paid them thirteen thousand dollars.
This would have been in twenty fourteen probably
March, April 2014 and went through the lawful
disclosure process.
So I met with the State Department inspector
general, the NSA inspector general, House
and Senate Intelligence Committees and others,
and eventually went through the pre-publication
review process and published an op ed in The
Washington Post about this problem.
So essentially, you believe that ordered 12
triple three was being misused in order to
surveil Americans when as as it was written,
you believe it was not meant to apply to Americans?
Yeah, that's right.
It was originally before the Internet.
There were two legal regimes, a statutory
regime for.
Intelligence agency operations inside the
United States, which is under fire, that the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act and
then twelve triple three was meant to cover
all the operations outside of our borders.
With the Internet, that distinction between
inside our borders and outside our borders
became almost irrelevant, much less relevant
and.
A whole bunch of Americans data is stored
in data centers around the world and it's
treated as foreign persons, the data and collected
as such by the NSA.
When we think about the government's treatment
of prominent and again, even the use of the
term whistleblower versus leaker, it's the
subject of debate and controversy.
So I'm not trying to sort of like prime the
discussion in any particular way.
But when we think about the treatment of folks
like Edward Snowden, Chelsea Manning, etc.,
you have a very wide range of opinion as to
how these individuals should should be treated.
On one side, you have the idea that strictly
speaking, if information was released in violation
of of how that information is classified or
if the information was obtained in a way that
violates the law or whatever, that that's
essentially all that matters that the content
really does in an individual's suit should
be punished as such.
On the other side, you have those who believe
that these are merely heroic acts that should
be celebrated and acted upon to change what
is the misbehavior of the government, including,
as you say, the misuse of of an executive
order, executive order in the case that you
discuss.
What is your general approach as to how individuals
should be treated by the government and by
the justice system?
Well, our motto, whistleblower aid is report
government and corporate lawbreaking without
breaking the law.
So we are a legal organization.
We would not never help anyone to leak classified
information.
With that said, these are very difficult questions.
There aren't easy answers.
And I think reasonable people can disagree
on some of this stuff.
You know, I we we created this organization
so that people wouldn't have to choose between
following their conscience and avoiding harm
to themselves.
So so we try to help people follow the available
lawful disclosure process.
There are often more options available than
many people realize.
And, you know, open up more options so that
people can keep their careers, don't have
to go to prison and still try to try to inform
the public about about what's going wrong.
You know, with those cases you mentioned those
you know, those people didn't feel like they
had other options.
And, you know, we are here to try to help
people not have to put their career or their
freedom in jeopardy, not not to be overly
conspiratorial or dystopian or whatever.
But one can imagine situations where one would
believe that the information they are they
are trying to disclose or what they are trying
to blow the whistle on is so damaging to the
government that going through the process
you describe might put them in jeopardy, might
put them in danger, might allow them maybe
to be silenced.
So is it at least theoretically conceivable
that people could be in a position where they
want to go the route that you help people
go, but they believe that starting that process
actually puts them at risk or may prevent
the information from going public?
Yeah, absolutely.
It's a risk.
There's no easy things here.
And the more the more important the disclosure,
the more significant it is, the more risky
it is for the individual.
And there's no way around that.
We're doing everything we can to minimize
those risks.
But the very first thing I tell people when
they come to me is, look, the safest thing
you can do is go home and never talk to anyone
about this again.
So, you know, most people, by the time they
get to me, they've they've crossed that bridge
in there.
They want to explore their options for going
forward.
But, you know, it's it's risky and I would
never say otherwise.
Can you talk a little bit for folks in our
audience who might be thinking about WikiLeaks
and the way that WikiLeaks has been an intermediary
with meant much information that have been
released?
Can you talk about how what you do is completely
different than what WikiLeaks does?
Absolutely.
We are not WikiLeaks.
We do not help people leak classified information.
We would never, you know, help someone.
Julian Assange has been accused of attempting
to help someone to to hack a government database
who would never help anyone trying to do that.
You know, look, that organization has been
credibly accused of, you know, working you
wittingly or unwittingly with Russian intelligence.
We would never do anything like that.
I swore an oath to the U.S. Constitution when
I was at the State Department.
I'm still bound by that oath and take that
very seriously.
So so we are very different from that approach.
You know, with that said, I'll say I don't
agree with all of the charges against Assange
in the sense that, you know, if the allegations
are true and I don't know the facts, it certainly
would be illegal to try to help someone hack
a government database.
I think publishing things receives from someone
else shouldn't is not illegal and should not
be illegal.
So it's a complicated legal matter when it
comes to the Ukraine whistleblower.
Can you talk a little bit about do you believe
that?
I mean, this is an individual who became the
target of so many prominent people in the
public eye in the lead up to Donald Trump's
eventual impeachment, et cetera.
From your perspective, what did they go through
this process in the correct way?
Absolutely.
So they immediately sought legal counsel.
My colleague Andrew Vicci and Mark Zaid were
the lawyers for that who are part of our team
here at whistleblower aid.
From the very beginning, they were planning
how to do this in a lawful way that would
not expose the client to criminal prosecution
or even dismissal from their job inside a
U.S. intelligence agency.
That person is still employed.
They did follow all the rules.
They are entitled to legal protections.
I think they're an example of how the system
of how people do sometimes have more options
than they than they know about the legal process.
Here are very obscure.
Some of these statutes haven't been tested
very often.
And so we saw that with the attempts to get
this disclosure to Congress, it was bumpy.
The White House did try to block Congress
from receiving this in violation of the laws.
But ultimately, the lawyers, Andrew and Mark,
were able to get it to Congress.
So I certainly wouldn't say that our system
is flawless, but there are often more options
than people understand.
And in this case, the client did an amazing
job and is a true hero.
Were you able to or let me rephrase it a different
way before the attempts to out and create
backlash against the whistleblower started?
Had you already anticipated that it would
reach the degree that it did?
And how did you advise the client to be prepared
for that in terms of security, in terms of
practical things?
Well, I have to be a little circumspect here,
first of all.
I never had any direct contact with the client,
Andrew and Marc.
My colleagues were the ones representing the
client.
Yeah.
You as they weren't duress.
Our firm.
So.
So I can't confirm or deny any kind of, you
know, things about that person's identity
or anything like that.
Broadly speaking, as soon as it was clear
that this implicated the president and the
2020 election.
Yes.
It was obvious that this was going to be a
very high profile matter, that there were
gonna be security concerns from day one.
We brought in top level security people on
the digital side, on the physical side, as
you may know, Mark Zaid, one of the lawyers.
He was getting death threats.
We had armed guards on mark seed 24 hours
a day, four months.
We.
And now the Department of Justice is bringing
a criminal prosecution against one of the
individuals who was threatening to hurt Mark.
So it was a very serious, serious situation.
We knew that from the beginning and from the
beginning, we were taking steps.
That's really all I can say is it is this
once you understand the scope of what is going
on.
And again, without revealing any anything
particular in general terms, do you do extra?
I mean, I know that you say you always say
to a lot of the folks that come to you, the
easiest thing for you is to go back home and
never speak about this again.
But are there more conversations than normal
of that type given these particular circumstances?
I was not I never had a conversation with
this client, so I'm going to speak to that.
Fair enough.
When we look going forward, is there anything
that you believe took place?
In or surrounding the Ukraine whistleblower
situation that may sort of change the way
these things are potentially handled in the
future, both by a firm like yours representing
someone like this, but also the way that Congress,
the House of Representatives and others worked
in receiving the information.
Yeah.
Clearly, threats, intimidation, starting with
the president of the United States.
The president's family, senior officials,
U.S. senators, attempts to identify, intimidate
this person are extremely harmful, arguably
illegal in some cases.
You know, you could make the argument that
any kind of presidential effort to intimidate
a whistleblower itself constitutes an offense.
And.
So there were serious problems here.
Some of those people should be held accountable
for their actions.
It is never right to try to identify a whistleblower
with the knowledge that, you know, some extremists
would would would threaten that person, possibly
act violently against that person.
There need to be stronger protections in place.
Arguably, that kind of behavior should be
criminalized, which it's not today, except
in certain narrow circumstances.
And, you know, Congress needs to identify
the gaps that were apparent in the system
and and fill them with legislation.
And certainly there needs to be reforms.
Andrew and Mark publish The New York Times
op ed two or three weeks ago that laid out
some of their ideas for that.
So clearly there's room for improvement.
Yes.
Certainly an understatement.
I would say room for improvement for for sure.
In regards to a lot of the elements of how
this all went down.
John TYhe, former NSA whistleblower and attorney
who in 2017 founded Whistleblower Aid.
John, so great to speak to you and I really
appreciate your time today.
Thanks, David.